Speaker 1: We have been covering a number of
the different conspiracy theories, speculations
and reactions to different aspects
of what's been happening in Ukraine.
This includes the so-called bioweapons labs
biolabs. We've talked about it ad nauseum so far.
Today I'm going to scale up the crazy a little bit
for you. Lara Logan is a now a Fox Nation host. I
don't remember her full credentials. At one point,
I believe she was involved with 60 Minutes, and
a lot of different things have happened with
Lara Logan, but she does appear to have gone
completely off the deep end cuckoo for cocoa
puffs. And her latest claims this this is just
completely outrageous. She. Said that, first
of all, she does soft anti-Semitic propaganda,
repeats Russian propaganda and also starts
to take a sort of supernatural, occult,
demonic perspective on what is happening.
You have to see this to believe it. Let's
just jump into the first clip. And by the way,
this is all happening on Real America's voice,
so even the venue in which the conversation
is happening is whacked. Take a listen.
Something is very wrong with Lara Logan.
Speaker 2: What troubles me about the moment
that we're in is that we have such a selective and
a narrow reading of history. You know, President
Zelensky may be Jewish, but he's not the only one
in this who suffered during the Second World War,
whose ancestors suffered right. I mean, look
at Putin. How many relatives did he lose
in the siege of St. Petersburg?
Speaker 1: So, so right off the bat?
Zelensky may be Jewish. There may be a history
of anti-Semitism, but other people have also
suffered like Putin. Oh OK, all right, go on.
Speaker 2: People don't know their history. They
don't know what made Vladimir Putin and I'm
going to defend, you know, I'm not defending
him. I don't need to defend Vladimir Putin.
Speaker 1: Well, these are sort of the soft
apologia that we've seen of Putin. And it's
also not that heavily veiled anti-Semitic
stuff as tough as well. I mean, what? What is
it, Zelensky's Jewish? But I mean, what is she
even talking about? And then it really goes off
the rails if you think this is wacky, just way.
Speaker 2: My job as a journalist is to try to
understand what is the truth here. I don't like
being lied to and we're being lied to on an
epic scale when we're told your only choices.
You have to be 100 percent with Zelensky, who's
a puppet who you can find on the internet in
black stilettos and leather pants, you know,
shirtless doing a spoof, Dancing with the Stars
kind of entertainment VIDEO. That's a mock
of a Ukrainian group that does this kind of
satanic occult type of music.
Speaker 1: VIDEO So now she's raising
that Zelensky has been involved in satanic occult
stuff. That's completely outrageous. The guy was a
comedian. OK, now you could say, well, a comedian
shouldn't be president or you might say a failed
businessman shouldn't be president. Sure, we can
have that conversation. But what on earth is she
talking about? What on earth is she talking about?
Speaker 2: And I mean, Zelensky was selected like
so many of our leaders. And honestly, with with
Big Tech and with election fraud these days,
we don't know how many leaders all around
the world have been selected for us.
Speaker 1: And now that's another one of
these. Russell's teapot, sort of. We talked
about Russell's teapot yesterday. She doesn't
actually have any evidence that Zelensky won
due to election fraud or due to Big Tech.
She doesn't have any evidence. If she had it,
I guess she would present it, although I don't
know. Maybe she doesn't even care about evidence.
I'm not sure, but it's accepted by
Ed Henry and the host. Oh, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. And it puts everybody else in
the position of having to disprove that Zelensky
won due to. It's the same thing that they do here
Speaker 2: actually voted in. But what we do know
is that there are increasing problems with
technology and the digitization of our world
because we look at what's happening with COVID,
Speaker 1: OK,
Speaker 2: like, you know what has happened
globally? We are fighting the same battles all
over the world to pretend that this war is about
Russia and Ukraine is a just a bare faced. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So there's a lot of really important
things here. One of the themes these people all
have the same themes, right? One of the themes is
you're not being told the truth, and it may not
even be possible to know the truth because there's
so many people trying to lie to you and all these
different things. And it's sort of hard, hard to
know that number two, making situations that are
about something appear to be far more complicated
than they are now. Is this when you think about
the history and fall of the USSR? Vladimir Putin's
personal history, the history of Ukraine, the
history of Naito, the history of there, there's
a lot there and there's a lot of history to know.
But all of these, it's too complicated
to even understand it. Type analyzes
are designed to softly make people question
whether Russia was wrong to invade Ukraine.
And let's go to the we'll go to one more
clip here and here. I mean, this is I
cannot emphasize how bonkers this interview is.
Speaker 2: I mean, this is on throughout the
Ukrainian major. You can see that black sign of
the occult on their body armor, even on the female
soldiers who are paraded in front of the world
is being, you know, such an example of Ukraine's
independence and spirit and nobility.
Speaker 1: It's all satanic and it's
all the occult. It's all crazy. I mean,
it's it's half a step before saying there
are Ukrainian witches and we've got to burn
Speaker 2: them and they are wearing the
black son of the occult. I mean, this is on.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so completely off the rails,
Lara Logan. And I mean, listen,
every time I talk about her,
if I if I don't mention this, people
email me and say, I'm wrong to mention it.
I'm sorry if I don't, if I don't mention
it, people say I'm wrong, not to mention it.
But when I mention it, people say that doesn't
really matter. She's out of her mind. Lara
Logan was assaulted. I believe it was when she was
covering the revolution in Egypt. That's terrible.
She may be suffering PTSD. She and any anything
may be going on. Her perspective on COVID has
been whacked. I mean, just whacked. And
now this kind of like veiled anti-Semitism,
Putin, apollonia, their satanic occult stuff going
on. This is wacky, wacky stuff. And to whatever
degree this has to do with what she experienced?
I don't know. But I'll put it all out there.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.